[Aplausos]
[Música]
amigos venezuela puede estar a punto de
experimentar un cambio histórico
este es un momento crucial
para el pueblo de venezuela por primera
vez da la sensación de que podemos estar
a punto de presenciar el fin de la
revolución bolivariana
camón
dando nuestro apoyo al presidente no hay
dos porque no estamos de acuerdo con lo
que está forzando en venezuela porque lo
que nos ha tocado salir prácticamente
exiliado es que queremos que vuelva a la
justicia venezolano y la libertad como
todos sabéis este hombre juan guaidó el
presidente de la asamblea nacional de
venezuela ha sido proclamado presidente
interino del país cada vez se ve
más cercano ese momento de libertad y la
mayor parte de las potencias mundiales y
casi todos los países latinoamericanos
ya la han reconocido como tal
7 que al día
en las week
[Música]
allais enrique juan guaidó als de
internet frente al venezuela el gobierno
de españa anuncia que reconoce
oficialmente al señor o aído márquez
como presidente encargado de venezuela
colombia reconoce a juan guaidó como
presidente de venezuela a juan guaidó
como presidente encargado del parlamento
votó como todos nosotros lo conocimos
como un presidente interino
se olvidó el cable
[Aplausos]
[Música]
todo ello junto a las nuevas sanciones
de eeuu que han congelado los ingresos
del petróleo han puesto al régimen
bolivariano contra las cuerdas
weiss
expansión de este juego pues amigos el
escenario al que se enfrenta ahora
nicolás maduro es complicado muy
complicado por un lado su autoridad ha
sido discutida y la oposición popular es
incontestable por otro lado el país está
a punto de colapsar del todo porque
amigos está a punto de quedarse sin
dólares y sin gasolina sí sin gasolina
habéis escuchado bien hasta ahora
venezuela importaba un montón de
gasolina de estados unidos fijaos
[Música]
se debe se importa el 70 por ciento de
la gasolina que consume el mercado
interno pero claro ahora sin dólares
todo eso se terminó y la pregunta es
puede un país sobrevivir sin gasolina y
sin petróleo a mí me da que no y sabéis
que nicolás maduro y sus secuaces lo
saben saben que su tiempo puede estar a
punto de terminarse para siempre pero un
momento llegados a este punto hay dos
preguntas que tenemos que responder cómo
ha sobrevivido tanto tiempo este régimen
chavista hoy pilotado por nicolás maduro
y la segunda será posible una transición
pacífica amigos son dos preguntas con
los mismos protagonistas atentos
[Música]
la gestapo bolivariana
no no nos engañemos cambiar venezuela va
a ser una tarea difícil muy pero que muy
difícil aunque se marche nicolás maduró
la revolución bolivariana no sólo ha
saqueado y destruido la economía
venezolana también ha creado un montón
de reveses e intereses de todo tipo
algunas de estas redes son precisamente
las que han permitido que nicolás maduro
siga hoy en el poder
[Música]
hablamos de dos instituciones claves en
todo el entramado chavista una la
temible policía secreta del régimen
organizada en el sebin el servicio
bolivariano de inteligencia nacional la
otra las faes las fuerzas de operaciones
especiales hablamos de dos
organizaciones que no han dudado en
secuestrar encarcelar robar reprimir y
dar de baja opositores y personas a las
que el régimen chavista consideraba una
amenaza
dos organizaciones que se han convertido
en la auténtica guardia pretoriana de
nicolás maduró y que si se produjera un
cambio de gobierno probablemente
seguirían operando en la sombra
dedicándose a lo que ya se dedican el
robo la extorsión y el narcotráfico pero
amigos como surgieron estas
organizaciones cómo funcionan qué papel
tienen realmente eso es precisamente lo
que vamos a ver
[Música]
esto no es algo nuevo todas las
dictaduras suelen utilizar grupos
armados para consolidar su poder para
alimentar el miedo a discrepar del
gobierno y ya puestos para eliminar
opositores
tal vez a lo largo del siglo 20 los tres
casos más conocidos han sido los de
mussolini que tuvo a su servicio a la
organización para la vigilancia y la
represión del antifascista los de stalin
con el comisariato del pueblo para
asuntos internos y el de los nazis con
la gestapo
la misión de todas estas organizaciones
no fue mantener la seguridad o
preocuparse por la justicia sino
consolidar el poder de sus gobiernos
dictatoriales
pues bien en el caso de venezuela esto
no es diferente la función de estos
cuerpos pasa por proteger a personajes
como diosdado cabello y mensaje pero a
diosdado cabello quien ha dicho que va a
convocar elecciones para elegir una
nueva asamblea nacional ese es un
individuo que es un narcotraficante una
persona que yo realmente en el presta
mucha atención porque no sé si va a ser
un mes m se termina en cárcel en algún
lugar para él no hay futuro y amigos a
medida que la crisis económica ha ido
creciendo estos dos grupos armados el
sebin y las ffaa se han ido
incrementando su actividad
[Música]
sin ir más lejos tras el juramento de
why do como presidente nicolás maduro
utilizado estas organizaciones para
tratar de frenar las protestas públicas
y aquí os a una pregunta sabéis qué
métodos han utilizado para tratar de
lograr este objetivo seguro seguro que
acertéis porque siempre es el mismo tan
solo en la primera semana tras la
proclamación de juan guaidó se calcula
que 35 personas fueron dadas de baja
fueron víctimas de estos criminales y
más de 800 fueron detenidas
hombre el trabajo sucio de la revolución
veréis con el supuesto objetivo de
combatir la creciente violencia que
vivía el país en el año 2015 nicolás
maduró creó la olp operación de
liberación del pueblo un despliegue
cuyos resultados fueron terribles para
los venezolanos
fijaos entre el año 2015 y el año 2016
se calcula atentos en 18.000 los casos
de detenciones arbitrarias allanamientos
sin orden judicial y ejecuciones con
toda esta experiencia en 2017 el régimen
creó las faes las fuerzas de acciones
especiales un grupo de intervención con
un entrenamiento especial y
procedimientos muy particulares fijaos
primero toman militarmente una zona como
si se tratase de un ejército de
ocupación y proceden a cazar a sus
objetivos no se trata de la seguridad
ciudadana no en su caso ellos entienden
que tienen que llegar a dar de baja a
elementos que no son personas sino
enemigos del régimen gamer ávila
las fases están actuando en los barrios
populares con efectivos uniformados de
negro y dotados con sofisticados equipos
de combate josé vicente rangel ex
vicepresidente de la república y ex
ministro de defensa
[Música]
amigos para que nos entendamos todos
podemos decir que las faes han hecho de
la brutalidad su bandera y ojo no sólo
llevan a cabo operaciones arbitrarias
con una brutalidad enorme también se han
convertido en muchos casos en auténticos
grupos criminales que han hecho del robo
el crimen organizado y la extorsión toda
una fuente de ingresos
[Música]
y todo lo hacen de la mano de los
llamados colectivos grupos
parapoliciales creados armados y
financiados por el régimen chavista
fueron creados en 2002 con la idea de
controlar directamente los barrios de
esta forma a los venezolanos que
discreparan el régimen ya no estarían
controlados solo por la policía y los
servicios de inteligencia también por
algunos de sus propios vecinos
controlados y por supuesto atemorizados
porque amigos en muchos casos estos
colectivos ejercen su propia autoridad y
en no pocas ocasiones han montado sus
propios negocios tan bien ligados al
narco y de la extorsión pues bien las
faes suelen montar operativos de la mano
de estos colectivos os imagináis otro
país donde la policía actúe de la mano
de bandas criminales bueno ahora que lo
digo se me ocurre otro país nicaragua
anda mira por donde otro aliado de
maduro por su parte el sebin el poderoso
servicio bolivariano de inteligencia
nacional creado por hugo chávez en 2010
no se queda atrás venezuela tiene un
conjunto de enemigos ocultos
de gente que simula y utiliza la
libertad pública
para conspirar contra la paz la
tranquilidad de la república y el sebin
ha sido un instrumento extraordinario
para
neutralizar lo veréis los agentes del
sebin símbolo de la represión en
venezuela son los encargados de las
operaciones más delicadas como la
detención y la persecución de opositores
aunque se traten de diputados de la
asamblea nacional del mismísimo
parlamento venezolano el sebin se ha
convertido en uno de los símbolos del
terrorismo de estado que se ha venido
implantando en venezuela es un organismo
que ha desarrollado una política de
graves violaciones a los derechos
humanos
marino alvarado a día de hoy estos dos
grupos operan con total impunidad y en
la sombra del sebin por ejemplo no se
sabe con cuántos agentes cuenta el
cuerpo a cuántas personas tienen
realmente detenidas o quién manda en sus
diferentes departamentos lo único que
sabemos es que está bajo las órdenes de
este hombre manuel christopher tijera
que podría ser controlado en gran medida
por tarek el aissami vicepresidente
económico de venezuela un tipo que es
considerado por los eeuu como todo un
narco y tenemos la grata visita y nos
honra con su presencia el señor josé
luís álvarez
es director general de air europa
sabemos eso y que este servicio ópera
con tanta impunidad que incluso hace
caso omiso a los propios tribunales
bolivarianos sí sí me explico
ay
se sabe en muchos casos donde presos
políticos a los que la propia justicia
bolivariana ha ordenado poner en
libertad siguen en la cárcel porque al
ser vil simplemente no le da la gana
soltar los queridos amigos de visual
político este edificio que veis en las
imágenes es tal vez la mayor prueba del
desastre que ha sufrido venezuela
durante las últimas décadas veréis me
explico este edificio de aspecto
futurista que evoca la torre de babel el
helicoide empezó a construirse ni más ni
menos que el año 1956 y tenía como
objetivo albergar un punto comercial y
un hotel de lujo hoy unas cuantas
décadas después es una de las dos
principales sedes del civil aquí es
donde tiene sus calabozos unos calabozos
que como seguro ya os imagináis tiene
unas condiciones terribles los calabozos
no tienen baños ni te garantizan
atención médica a los presos los tienen
encerrados casi siempre pueden pasar
semanas o meses para que te dejen salir
por algunos minutos al exterior jamás se
me olvidará que el inspector que me
recibió tras mi detención me dijo
bienvenido al infierno
vilca fernández ex candidato a la
asamblea nacional y si los agentes del
sebin cobran a las familias por llevar
por ejemplo alimentos a la cárcel
por supuesto va al bolsillo de los
propios agentes pero recapitulando
sabéis cuál ha sido el resultado que han
dejado atrás de estos grupos en los
últimos años
[Música]
pues amigos según las informaciones de
la organización de estados américanos
podríamos estar hablando de más de ocho
mil ocho mil ejecuciones
fundamentalmente a manos de estos grupos
tan sólo desde el año 2015 y ojo porque
los datos del observatorio venezolano de
la violencia son aún peores según esta
organización tan solo en 2018 los
cuerpos de seguridad habían dado de baja
a más de 7500 personas en un solo año
ya lo veis estos dos grupos no solo han
sido el brazo armado de nicolás maduró
su soporte vital para mantenerse en el
poder sino que llegaba a la hora del
cambio probablemente sean todo un
quebradero de cabeza sí hoy estos grupos
ya tienen vínculos con el narco no
serían nada pero que nada extraño que
luego esto se convirtiera en su
actividad principal pero de todo esto ya
hablaremos
ahora turno para ti te hago una pregunta
clave crees que hay que ofrecer una
amnistía por todos sus crímenes a los
líderes que han secuestrado saqueado y
destruido a venezuela déjame tu
respuesta en los comentarios y también
que nos lo pedís mucho en esta encuesta
amigos y como siempre si os resulta
interesante este vídeo no olvidéis en
darle a like y compartirlo con vuestros
amigos eso y por supuesto suscribiros a
visual política un saludo y hasta la
próxima
- solo tiene un conjunto de enemigos
ocultos de gente que simula y utiliza la
libertad pública para conspirar contra
la paz la tranquilidad de la república y
el sebin ha sido un instrumento
extraordinario
a neutralizarlo